The better the teacher,
the better the world.
And the better the world,
the better our lives will be.
You need to be born a SEN teacher.
I love my job.
I can't imagine doing anything else.
A SEN teacher gives
all their body, heart and mind.
But also all their energy,
which they use and which I use
to guarantee the best
and most comprehensive development
for my children,
because they are my children.
In 2012 I did a job shadowing
at the Oathall Community College
in Haywards Heath, UK,
where I learnt new art techniques
such as papier-mâché,
decoupage, ceramics
and jewellery-making.
The teachers at my school were very
interested in the techniques I'd learnt
in the United Kingdom.
I did micro-teaching sessions,
workshops,
newsletters on art techniques.
The job-shadowing programme
has encouraged other teachers
to take part in similar initiatives.
Art plays a very important role
in educating disabled people.
It is a key to a better understanding
of the world.
Through their artwork
children express their feelings,
they show us their mind,
sometimes their thoughts.
Thanks to their work, we can find out
the best things about them.
Even though they can't speak or hear.
But they feel and express it
through their work.
I have also worked together
with the parents,
showing them the potential
and the skills their children have
and how they can utilise them
in their future working life.
Erasmus+ has allowed me to open up
and accept new opportunities,
has helped me express myself
and believe in myself,
which allows me to apply everything
in my work at the school.